- [Narrator] Diagnostic
pelvic laparoscopy is used
to examine the internal
organs of the pelvis
in an effort to identify
a specific problem.
You might be advised
to undergo diagnostic pelvic laparoscopy
if you have pelvic pain or a mass,
an abnormal accumulation of fluid,
or difficulty becoming pregnant.
These may be caused by endometriosis,
tubal pregnancy, an ovarian cyst or tumor,
scarring from pelvic
infections, or other conditions.
Laparoscopic techniques require
only tiny keyhole incisions
or puncture wounds,
and the recovery period is much shorter
and more comfortable.
When you arrive at the
hospital for your procedure,
an intravenous line will be started,
and you may be given a
sedative to help you relax.
Pelvic laparoscopy is done
under general anesthesia,
which will put you to sleep
for the duration of the operation.
A breathing tube will
be temporarily inserted
through your mouth and into your throat
to help you breathe during the operation.
A catheter will also be placed
in your bladder to drain your urine.
An uncomplicated diagnostic
laparoscopy may take
as little as 30 to 60 minutes.
Your surgeon will gain access
to the interior of your pelvis
by using a sharp
instrument called a trocar
to make a small 1/2-inch opening or port
just below your navel or umbilicus.
Carbon dioxide gas will then be pumped
through this umbilical port
to puff up your abdomen
so its contents can be viewed more easily.
Next, your surgeon will
insert the laparoscope
through the umbilical port.
Images from its camera are projected
onto a video monitor
in the operating room.
Your surgeon will carefully
examine your pelvic organs
and tissues, looking for signs of disease
that might explain your symptoms.
He or she may create other ports
through which instruments can be slipped.
These additional instruments are used
to move organs out of the
way for better viewing
or to perform operative procedures,
such as removing scar tissue,
taking biopsies, or
draining abnormal fluid.
When the laparoscope and
other instruments are removed,
a special gas valve is
left in place briefly
to allow all the carbon dioxide
to escape from the abdomen.
The keyhole incisions are closed
with just a few sutures or staples
and then covered with bandages.
After your surgery, your
breathing tube will be removed,
and you will be monitored
in the recovery area.
Your catheter will be
removed shortly thereafter,
and you will be given
pain medication as needed.
Your intravenous line will come out
when you can drink liquids.
Most patients are released
within a few hours of the procedure.